yo what is up everybody my name is
prestige or the prestige plan as you
might know by my youtube and this is not
another episode of the divine survival
series this is a return of the hero
brain experience so yeah so hello to
anybody that's new this is ariel what
you'll learn enough about what this year
is about survival and to all my
subscribers you might notice I'm missing
to my armor my chic hacks all that good
stuff and that's because I took out the
I have taken out the divine RPG mod I'm
running on one point six point two so
the newest version of Minecraft and I
have a different hair urban lot in so
yeah because basically because oh oh
just yeah I why I didn't really care for
divine RPG too much so and I feel like
you guys like uh it seems like you guys
like my survivor series more for the
aspect of just the overall series not
much the mod so today we're gonna be
really fixing everything up so like my
portal room my chest stuff like that
like we're gonna need to make new tools
going on the doorway now all right so
like see this chest gonna need a break
and also i'll show you why it's a
heroine mod and yeah so let's make some
tools first off we're going to look at
let's go make some sticks so first off
i'm going to want a sword because we
need a sword and then up hick so pick um
I'll do shovel and acts we have a full
set full set of the goods throw these
diamonds back in and also because I'm
running 1.6 point2 not one point four
point seven I can make all of this good
stuff
much more compact do do do right now
it's half some of these blocks all right
that should be good and I think give
enough for one more haha and then let's
see with the coal apologies if this
isn't the most super amazing / 15 stuff
you've ever seen in your life block of
court look so funky looks like obsidian
tenten tenten and I let's put up there
and we should have enough for perfect a
39 are legit now we can go through the
coal right there the resin right there
and that right there we could make this
into blocks but we'll save that for a
another time and oh one thing that I
didn't make when I was it no I wanted to
think of those in so also i need to make
armor so one thing basically uh the mod
i'm using is called like the fan mod so
we need the fam guide and if we take a
look-see in here I'll have one of them
so we can chew we have chuck norris hair
been a notch now these three things
they're going to become a little entity
right to the right of me like mochi and
they're going to let me do certain
things so let's go check it out so open
fan guide now sergeant Chuck Norris
Chuck Norris will let us around us cake
by pressing arch the tree Norse is
completely overpowered by the way
heroine will make a lettuce teleport and
cost two hearts for each teleport and
notch will let us check lightning down
upon our foes well right now we're going
to be in Haran so we're going to go over
here and 25 x that's a lot of XP we've
unlocked him now will equip him now we
have ourselves that hair burn her body
hard here now armor doesn't make me news
anymore
just going to do right now let's see if
I do our are well I see you got the
teleport power and he is impervious to
anything so yeah and yam I'm going to
get back inside so we're gonna have to
fix a smiley face we're gonna actually
right now let's go let's go try and fix
this a bit like snow do I bring the
shovel yeah rate with shuttle so this is
going to just become the nether portal
room think probably the best option um
this room is just beautiful um let's see
what should i do which it's what am i
hearing sounds like I'm hearing like
okay let's other music in a bit I'm
gonna hear in zombie pigmen probably am
um which I'm filling in this so that's
it that's plated with the block you guys
stuff tear I then let's just get this up
Derek which rendered it and boom boom
all the way I'll see you will obviously
make this better in time but also when
they upgrade other urban mon-sol glad
does her fun let's see how well I can
teleport o.o hahaha it was a little a
little farther than I had anticipated
but ok we'll take it
all right now let's go hit up the guys
an iron armor I've only a little more to
the full set it sights and do this up
let me go now iron chest plates on
helmets and ireland's yeah or a few off
so that's good for now still need a
relatively powered up also we need to
get a horse it's going to be the next
plan of action so the fam got um can I
ploetz see if I can put this in like
okay also so I need to assure you yes
three chests and he signs in here and
yeah we have some torches so let's get
some more I just get that all right it's
pretty good yeah we don't really need
ender pearls anymore because we have
missed ahead open it let's see should I
upgrade do a level 13 chat on a pic on a
sword well let's see a protection 3
efficiency for that efficiency for is
pretty nice sharpness 3po one with that
I'm breaking I'm breaking to an
efficiency for I think I'll put on my
chubbies one nothing I really want um
got multiple sharpness 3 e's protection
3 efficiency for how will I just test
our luck with a plus 5 tekken 7 that
should be a little more but i shall we
go for just 30 get to it i'm breaking
three fish see through so more balanced
than the other one and it's still a
great pick so that's the chip and what
to do what to do what to do lets our
little buddy was stuck in there let's
let's like to do something with that
let's rebuild smiley case oh oh oh what
you doing out there alright time to put
our power to work but hon ooh no don't
go to my house back up back up back up
back up shoot that arrow awledge it can
we give me give me good it is XP back
in-house thinking about it goes in here
right three but let's say it goes in
there alright so we're gonna want to
recreate it out of let's get glowstone
for the smiley part and let's make like
sand would be good sound false and stone
like same good let's let's get the other
sandstone sandstone let's turn this hand
I think it's like this yeah it's in
stone our perfect 4141 should be enough
I don't really recall
is mr. Herriman still there bro are you
doing with the urban let's test you so
yeah he's still with us mr. urban just
hide him who oh I thought I was like a
flying zombie in my house okay um let's
sleep other monsters me but of course
there are my play monster oh yeah we
love the monsters okay you're dead die
Wow after you I didn't drop any of your
gold pantaloons out of fishes I got some
onto that bottom yeah are we good Wow
there are a lot of zombies oh we're good
can I sleep chez panisse II do I want to
replace any torches there with one have
a good old glowstone for the smiley face
all right now I do not completely
remember this from before will do this
believe this um excuse dirt is our
little other block and two one let's put
all these blocks near each other and one
and then dirt and then one that'll be
good let's let's just look at it over
here and one then start so we can get
back up it down yeah that's good and
then we put flowstone right here
okay that we can good and so obviously
going to take the dirt out yeah let's
get for a smiley face up up let's go
let's go up to from what we have and we
can just fill this in and I was looking
up looking looking pretty good we can
put the eyes like right can't put next
to each other right there like that and
flatten guys looking good and then if
you want to close it off just like that
or do you want to put another later like
that um oh let me let me test something
oh yeah so we can do giant jumps and
only lose to ok let's say wow exactly
what I planned but uh it works one of my
armor takes damage from that now let's
let it go away let's see what it looks
like right like that get the shovel out
here
ok let's take you let's go back ganna
eat nom I think I'm sure I think it
looks good yeah looks good r it's time
to get back up there Oh cha I and always
fun right on top of it very nice drop
down and I'll shovel away all this
nastiness all right well up that looks a
little weird that should a little bit
more oh let me try something it's might
be kind of creepy smile but I like that
more yeah it's good all right now let's
teleport back down if it's so legit oh
my gosh her burn you helping us out so
much thank you and blocks just toss the
blocks let's check it in some of the
same next to each other you move the
glass over bits and yeah that's looking
good now we're going to want some
netherrack and we're going to want to go
and fix the nether background because
really it's looking bad um let's never
wrap this up
just get it flow all into the rack so we
can also destroy this Wow rights
netherrack second let's wrap this up oh
no oh little little ad placement bad
flash burn pride what you doing boy oh
gosh too much oh and then look this all
make it to back what listen hair brown
eyes look freaking me out just so much
to give the hair renegade hopping around
everywhere being all weird and let's I
not place blocking her there and so you
can have to get out of the way more
often are they looking up nope nope nope
okay
don't want to break that no all hang it
move this takes place that thing and yea
though nope that I was gonna say this
from so pretty good man it's nuts oh
that's look good I know what happened to
my portal sound yeah that's good uh uh
oh I broke some stairs oh I broke some
stairs uh no I don't want to get it
let's see Zach out oh my gosh this is a
little bit more alright that and then oh
my gosh head little harem dude you
better calm down all right let's uh
place like that's good there we go Wow
good we good home skin up we get home
skillet alright we've done Mason
basically all the additions and repairs
I already had gone sword ah well that's
a fail um toast netherrack in there
throw you only like the room i'm in is
just hot and also guys tell me in the
description how you feel that's
impossible cube will in the future
because that game looks sick nasty and i
want players so yeah all right next next
up next time on the prestige pan is
urban experience we go find ourselves a
horsey and we tame it when name a bit
above jus and I should probably get like
tough to get the horse back so back to
the house oh my teleportation power
alright guys I hope you enjoyed hope you
enjoyed this throwback bring back
whatever you want to call it to the old
series and hopefully hair brune is
powerful okay guys if you've got this
far I hope you leave a like comment rate
and subscribe and I'll see you all next
time peace out